[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
over the guy that came up before me and
he almost
took my sponges now that was gonna
shake me and bug me like those mexicans
like to do
but uh i'm gonna be asian
sorry
[Music]
this is america and we're gonna build a
wall around you
uh thank you to be here in trump's
america uh violence america
i love mexican people uh i think it's
funny that tanner is a white person's
name
i mean tanner then what
she'll be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner that's my black friend
tanist
i love the blacks uh my wife was like
dude the only reason
black people are bigger and stronger
than white people is because we bred
them as slaves to be that way
[Music]
dirty birdie dirty party
i was like well that was true why
wouldn't you do that to yourself think
of yourselves
and power instead of giving a superpower
to people who hate you
also why are you [ __ ] your cousin not
really the book of the genetic
scientists that one
but i love being here in the south uh
i'm a son or two
you know i'm from south korea yeehaw
[Music]
one two things i like commies and kpop
that's what we like right plastic
surgery and uh
dancing but yeah i'm asian or as i know
this country i'm chinese
from province province in china called
south korea
right next to the japan province
uh so yeah i'm from a province in china
so i'm sorry about the coronavirus but
bath soup is so good
you guys don't even know
it's like chick-fil-a mixed with
whataburger it's just
it was worth it it was worth it it's not
even a big deal to us
we're in nightclubs like you guys but
with less guilt it's
great though it's like a slumber party
after the parents go to sleep we're all
up but nobody should be up we're
partying survive here i love it
uh it's like we're doing it i think we
can do it i think we can cough on each
other now i think technically legally
i'm allowed to cough on you
look at florida look at texas we don't
give a [ __ ] we're doing it we got low
numbers
it's called the vaccine or i'd like to
call it western acupuncture
[Music]
[Music]
you know a lot of asian women they act
like they're hotter than asian men but
we look exactly the same you [ __ ]
i can throw on a wig and be a seven
hey
[Music]
someone who looks like a pale version of
aussie tonight
there's a white dude for everyone no
matter what you look like there's a dude
jerking off to you that's white
it's happening right now but i do love
being asian
because we produce the sexiest babies
how do you think asian women are created
mean [ __ ]
i'm a crucial part of the sexy process
please stop trying to skip me
if you have sex with me i children won't
be very beautiful
[Laughter]
a lot of people are like yeah you're
book smart but i'm street smart
oh you're smart in a way that's not
measurable or comparable
how convenient for you maybe
you're dumb and you're insecure about it
that's what you committed aggravated
assault
stop punching me it hurts
but i hate having autism i hate it when
people tell me this
but uh it's like autism sucks because
it's the only disease you diagnosed in a
bar
i was like hey this dude looks like he
has non-hodgkin's lymphoma
do you have carcinoma of the lungs let's
see the anger balls of this guy he looks
like he has leukemia
look at that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
telling me i have a disease
no i'm just asking i'm just asking do
you have answers this is a question well
do you have [ __ ] retardation of your
[ __ ] whatever
but uh yeah i mean uh you know i'm
pretty smart uh
i am a stapiosexual i'm uh looking for a
girlfriend who
looks like this guy no i'm uh
i'm a stephiosexual i'm looking for a
girlfriend who is intellectually
stimulated by the mental exercise of
finding me attractive
like a woman is into puzzles
my friends were like dude you need to
learn how to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn to
listen to hans
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
it's very interesting we're at a party
relax
did you know that my vagina is can make
a baby come out of it so technically my
vagina is a 3d printer
i was like actually technically your
womb is a 3d printer
your vagina is a tray
[Applause]
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
[Applause]
takes nine months to print
[Music]
and the whole time it's printing is
complaining
not exactly what i look for in a 3d
printer
needless to say i did not send any trays
that night
but my friends were like dude we're so
lucky we're not gay can you imagine that
most of the gender you were attracted to
wasn't attracted to you back
i was like whoa can't even imagine
they must cry a lot but i do think women
are the sexiest gender in the human race
uh definitely in the top 32.
i don't think i could ever [ __ ] a dude
sorry fellas
i never looked at a beautiful woman and
been like wow she's gorgeous but is
there a version of her that's bigger and
hairier and has less kindness
[Applause]
i want to put that in my butthole
never happens straight as [ __ ]
please believe me my dad does that
but uh i'm not gay i love the ladies
but it's difficult for me to have sex
because 99 of my sex career was so low
so i don't come all the time but it's
not my fault uh
like i'm coming solo for 99 of my sex
career now i have to have an orgasm when
someone's breathing on me [ __ ] on my
glasses
[Applause]
i know what my name is you don't have to
keep saying it
where's my office chair i'm gonna come
[Music]
a lot of ladies like to call me a
premature ejaculator which is so
offensive
pretty mature to you i came right at the
perfect time when i fell
amazing
it takes maturity yourself now i'm
coming like oh
the lady it seems like i have claim upon
your chest
very mature now a post-mature
ejaculation but uh yeah i mean
women like what's the deal with them
they don't think they're better than us
but we were funnier than them
yeah yeah no i'm a feminist
my sister is also a feminist or as i
like to call her a sore loser
get over it
my sister is a christian and she's also
asian which is kind of weird because the
people wrote the bible didn't seem to
know that asians existed
they couldn't even drop us a line hey
asians great job on inventing the
fireworks and the compass
really proud of you anyways back to the
jews
who did nothing what did they do
well they uh did a lot of [ __ ] later but
uh yeah uh
we're pretty rocking during the [ __ ]
biblical era they don't even drop us a
line
goddammit jesus talk about us
but uh my sister has uh what would jesus
do bracelet
and i very rarely see her behaving like
a jewish carpenter
[Music]
build a birdhouse speak hebrew
commit we'll see an asian woman
but i'm an atheist now because i'm not
in kindergarten and i have an internet
connection
i think it'd be stressful to have an
ideology that can be destroyed by facts
you're like walking down the street oh
look a fossil [ __ ]
i guess i could have been blowing dudes
this whole time
but i'm not gay uh please believe me um
i like how people will say it's adam and
eve not adam and steve but
adam and eve were not even a good couple
biblically
first of all they disobeyed god and they
entered fruit they weren't supposed to
eat which is kind of gay
and then they came murdered abel
or you take a parenting advice from
people raised a murderer
there are only three other people on
earth he killed a quarter of the world's
population
i drive to work every day i don't kill
anyone he had the whole earth
he could have just moved stick around
the one guy he hated
uh but yeah i mean uh you know gays are
pretty cool
uh i'm not gay though i am single
i have uh yet to meet my soul mate i'm
beginning to think maybe it's her fault
she needs to get out more
yeah yeah yeah she's like a loser
but um i love girlfriends i used to date
this one girl who was really into yoga
and choke sex and i was like do you
enjoy breathing or not
i want to work out to catch the ladies
you know i just want to have enough
strength where if a girl puts her hand
on my chest i don't have to take a step
back
i don't have mass well yeah i mean uh
it's hard to date as an asian man
everyone thinks we have a small penis
which even if it was true and it's not
it's pretty big
but even if it was it's not like we'd
hear that and be like oh we got small
dicks okay we'll go find a new hobby
sorry to bother you
we want to just give up we'll start
studying because that's what we do
we let her know they use it like a
sewing machine
[Music]
this orgasm brought to you by panasonic
[ __ ] asian playstation to know what
it's like to uh [ __ ] a
scuba suit a dude a scuba suit
um but yeah i mean uh
you know a lot of people make fun of us
because we dogs which i understand is
very shocking
but we eat dogs because they have bigger
dicks
but uh i know like it's shocking
because in america dogs are treated like
family members but in asia we treat our
family members like family members
this real little tradition we have back
home where instead of buying an animal
we love our grandmother
we should everyone better in asia unless
you're a baby girl in case you throw it
in the river
but everyone else is
because whenever someone is racist to me
i'm like oh you hate respectful people
who
keep to themselves okay good luck
finding an affordable care
my asian friends make fun of me all the
time because i like to eat general says
chicken
i'm like he's making great chickens it's
my general
yeah apologies
my asian friends are like this is
chicken just a shitty americanized
version of something authentically asian
i'm like yeah but so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour three
[Music]
[Music]
do you think people in mexico were about
to go to america
their friends like dude you're going to
america you know you can drink the
shower water over there
uh i think it's hilarious that people
tell mexican people to speak
english they're already speaking spanish
okay
spain is famously in europe they're
speaking a european language you
won how much more of a victory do you
need
you want them to speak your white person
language let them take the language they
were raped with they love it
uh i love all races you know i'm not
racist i'm a minority how could i be
impossible
i don't know i don't even see race i
only smell it
all races i don't understand racism i
mean i hate people too i just get to
know them first
uh my favorite marvel movie would have
to be the black panther movie because it
gave black children a hero they could
finally look up to
not just someone like will smith or
saint fortier
[Music]
um
nelson mandela jimmy hendrix eddie
murphy dave chapel
uh now there's a fake person that
dressed like a cat
congratulations
[Music]
what are they going to come out with a
yellow panda huh
that was our movie
it's gonna eat your furniture uh i love
white people amazing military wow you
gotta respect their military
but we'll exchange
[Music]
but a lot of people do it incorrectly
white private people are always
like the nazis or the confederate flag
they're never into building a castle or
yodling
that's not why pride that's racism you
have to be
white tape the jews i can do that too
[Laughter]
i love rednecks because rednecks can
survive in any wilderness situation that
you put them in
except the situation where everyone has
equal rights
you can live in a swamp with an
alligator why can't you live in a
cul-de-sac with a minority
make an effort but i love how
in prison they'll say don't drop the
soap
[Music]
should be don't pick up the soap
you can drop
butthole we'll never know rapists aren't
like that they're go-getters they don't
take no for an answer
even if you don't drop the soap you're
still gonna get raped
you're just gonna have really clean
hands while it happens
why isn't this working
all right that's my time thank you very
[Applause]
[Music]
much